For mobile users, activate English subtitles by
clicking on the three dots on the upper
right from desktop click the CC symbol
on the bottom right
That's it? Even if
nobody helps me I can eat that no
problem at least give me a challenge
this is Chandler's chicken
this is the turkey
how big is that?
It's about nineteen pounds.
It's like me when I was born.
All right who would like some yams, Will?
Oh you'd like that, wouldn't you?
What? Oh you know what can we please keep
the chicken and the turkey and
everything on the other side the table, the smell is just, yuck!
Typical
I'm sorry, what?
I said it was typical. Typical of you Rachel Green, Queen Rachel,
does whatever she wants in little
Rachel Land
Seriously, who is this guy?
I'm sorry do you have to do have a problem with me?
I don't know do I do I I
think you do
Apparently you were a little mean to him
in high school.
A little mean? You made my
life miserable.
I'm sorry I had no idea
I'm sorry.
Well you should be
screw it bring on the yams.
Will, but you've
worked so hard.
Yams! Ok!
Will, I just want to say that I'm real
sorry for whatever I did to you in high school.
It wasn't just me. We had a club.
You had a club
That's right.
The I hate Rachel Green Club
Oh my god so what you
all just joined together to hate me who
else was in this club me and Ross
No need to point. She knows who Ross is.
So you were in an I hate Rachel Club?
Yes he was.
No no.
So who else was in this club?
Actually there was also that
exchange student from Thailand but I
don't think he knew what it was.
So Ross we went out for two years and you never
told me you were in an I hate Rachel
Club?
You went out with her? We had a pact.
that was in high school it's not like it
was binding forever
Then why did it have the word eternity in it?
Ok. Monica did you know about this?
I swear I didn't.
Hey is that why you guys used to go up
to your bedroom and lock the door
Yeah.
Huh a little relieved I got to say.
Look Rachel I'm sorry okay I I was a
stupid kid okay the only reason I joined
Co-founded
Co-founded, co-founded the club was that I was insanely
in love with you obviously I didn't handle it very well.
But if you think about it the
I hate Rachel Club was really the I love Rachel Club.
Except that it was really
the I hate Rachel Club